en paca alors cette fois ci marine le
pen qui a choisi d'enjamber ce scrutin
s'approche d'elle du pouvoir ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'elle anticipait elle joue
déjà une carte on voit on va y revenir
c'est celle de l'union nationale comme
elle l'a fait au début du mois notamment
lors d'un passage en région rhône alpes
auvergne pour soutenir son candidat
andré ricaud tarak sept autour de la
candidature président de ma candidature
présidentielle que va s'organiser
l'union nationale que nous appelons de
nos voeux et nous ne regarderons pas car
à la différence de beaucoup de nos
adversaires ne nous ne sommes pas
sectaires ce que nous souhaitons c'est
que tous ceux qui aiment le pays nous
rejoignent et oeuvrent avec nous
travaillent avec nous quand on regarde
les sondages justement là où le
rassemblement national est bien placée
notamment le paca et les autres et même
les hauts de france
on voit que c'est des candidats
effectivement qui ne sont pas dans le
rassemblement national sont qu'ils sont
en tête
est-ce que ça selon vous jérôme un
impact est ce que ça valide ce genre de
et goûter bien sûr s'il est clair que
marine le pen a changé profondément de
stratégie ça n'est plus du tout la même
donc il faut avoir la lucidité de
regarder les choses c'est la stratégie
aujourd'hui une sorte de stratégie anti
philippon qui était son secrétaire
général c'est-à-dire d'abord sur les
thématiques le l'euro l'union européenne
il s'agit plus de dire on arrête tout ce
qui affolait une partie des français en
2017 sur l'économie le discours est
beaucoup plus raisonnable est également
il n'ya plus je dirais cette idée d'une
jonction des populistes de gauche et de
droite qui emporterait le système
politique là c'est une offensive très
clairement vers la droite
c'est à dire que l'analyse politique et
d'une extrême simplicité
l'effondrement des grands partis parti
socialiste et les républicains a ouvert
des béances considérable dans le jeu
politique pour les républicains il
s'agit et d'un côté il ya mc
et de l'autre le pen de manger ses deux
bouts le maximum possible et donc vous
avez raison la stratégie de marine le
pen a consisté par exemple thierry
mariani y est c'est un vieux cheval de
retour très franchement dont on pourrait
se dire il avait fui paca pour aller se
faire élire dans comme le représentant
chaîne des français de l'étranger et pas
de n'importe quel pays c'est en
particulier des pays de l'ex soviétique
dont il est un représentant fidèle et
bien mariani donc qu'ils avaient pu être
partie revient et la labilité de dire
moi je suis toujours de droite j'étais
ministre de sarkozy et je lui suis
fidèle
ce qui est évidemment assez audacieux
mais pour beaucoup d'électeurs de paca
finalement on a le choix entre un type
qui maintenant au centre droit est un
type qui est franchement à droite c'est
difficile d'en sortir comme piège et
vous avez donc beaucoup de régions où ça
se joue comme ça j'ajouterai que même
des thèmes sur laquelle savait qu'elle
marine le pen et est plus modérée s'est
montré plus modéré que la droite un
ensemble de sujets quand on pense
qu'elle a expliqué qu'il fallait
absolument rembourser la dette alors que
toute une partie de la droite devait n'a
pas dit comment jouer a nommé jeudi
paquet mais c'est intéressant en termes
de positionnement à l'époque de filippo
il aurait dit mais les dettes de vivo
tant que les états ou d'où vient cette
idée qu'il faut absolument rembourser la
dette non l esclavage des marchés
financiers l a dit il faut rembourser la
dette
un truc une partie de la droite veut pas
dire même chose sur une des lois
je sais plus laquelle maintenant
présentée par par darmana quand le quand
les républicains et l'afrique de sur le
séparatisme voilà sur la voie
séparatisme les répliques à votre contre
le front national s'abstient il est donc
plus pro gouvernance et c'est que c'est
vraiment affreux ont versé c'est une
vraie stratégie absolument réfléchi
absolument abouti de marine le pen
au point que même certains disent arbres
ça va lui coûter des d'autre des voies
sur la droite de sa droite parce
qu'elles semblent de ses électeurs
trouve qu'elle est trop - comme l'avait
dit d'ailleurs d'armagnac eu lui-même
s'en étaient étonnés de la trouver 6,6
sicile bénévoles hanté avait dit on va
vous allez vous êtes devenue toute molle
maintenant il explique que c'est le
diable or c'est un peu compliqué on
comprend pas très bien
la cohérence de tout ça juste sur ce
point sur le point de savoir ce qu'est
un électorat de droite très adroit très
à droite qui pourrait lui reprocher
d'être trop modéré
je le crois pas trop j'ai quand même le
sentiment d'abord que son image l'image
de la marque le pen est tellement
insisté m elle est tellement établi sur
les sujets notamment concernant
l'immigration que même si l arrondi les
angles
les gens considéraient considérons
toujours qu'elle en fasse davantage que
les autres pour appuyer d'un mot ce que
vient de dire alexis brézet c'est au
fond le calcul de marine le pen c'est
que ses fondamentaux sont suffisamment
solides pour qu'elle puisse jouer la
carte de l'apaisement politique
les fondamentaux c'est la sécurité
l'immigration il se trouve qu'avec la
qu'ovide et le quoi qu'il en coûte
tous les thèmes économiques et sociaux
ont été mis sous le boisseau
depuis un an ça c'est un changement est
ce qu'ils vont revenir dans l'année qui
vient
je dirais c'est l'intérêt de macron et
l'intérêt de la gauche parce que la
gauche a aussi disparue en particulier
parce qu'on ne parle plus du tout thèmes
économiques et sociaux
quand on a payé un chômage partiel à 11
millions de salariés pendant des mois on
peut difficilement dire que l'état
providence ne joue pas son rôle et c'est
donc on voit bien les fondamentaux
sécurité immigration et le poids de la
sécurité dans les derniers mois a été
évidemment considérable là dedans et du
coup elle joue la carte parce que ses
fondamentaux elle estime qu'ils sont
assez solides
elle joue la carte de l'apaisement si
vous voulez le problème macron le pen de
2022 si je puis dire le problème de
macron c'est absolument d'éviter de
rejouer jusqu'à remis terran de 80 c'est
à dire macron tisserait dans le rôle de
giscard d'un pouvoir lointain arrogant
dont on pense qu'il faut en sortir et
marine le pen qui s'installerait dans
une sorte de force tranquille
prince est elle la force tranquille pour
2022 est tout le problème évidemment
c'est de sortir de ce schéma khaled qui
me paraît extraordinairement juste à
dire que la stratégie de giscard teese
est de faire peur avec mitterrand les
chars soviétiques de diaboliser
mitterrand au fond la stratégie efficace
et de diaboliser mi temps mais diamants
que ça marche plus et c'est ça le risque
que court
macron celle et c'est ça dont les
régionales vont être un premier test
c'est de savoir est ce que cette
diabolisation marche encore
parce qu'au fond et ses cinq essais de
désarmer marine le pen partout de cette
stratégie de rassemblement et
d'apaisement
c'est de désarmer ce réflexe qui avait
été terrible lors des régionales de 2015
et et qui avait aussi été à l'oeuvre la
dent lors de la présidentielle de 2017
qui est que tout à coup les gens quand
ils la voient ou quand il voit ses
candidats disent non on a voté on a voté
vous mais on n'en veut pas on veut pas
qu'ils prennent le pouvoir
eh bien elle joue cette stratégie sera
sont loin les régionales région par
région vont permettre d'avoir déjà une
première idée de savoir si entre les
deux tours le finalement là la digue ces
fameuses dit que c'était le barrage dont
on nous parle et nous reparle à ce
qu'ils existent encore c'est pas
absolument certain alors sur sur ce
point là sur les régionales si on
regarde un peu les atouts marine le pen
est ce qu'on peut dire que du
rassemblement national
est ce qu'on peut dire que il ya un
atout par rapport aux scrutins
précédents c'est que lors du précédent
scrutin il y avait finalement peu glisse
donc il suffit qu'il y ait une liste de
droite ou une liste de gauche va une
deux listes de gauche qui se retirent et
hop il y avait eu front républicain
là il ya quand même beaucoup plus de
liste est ce que ça joue pas plus en
faveur du rassemblement national pour
qu'ils décrochent un ou deux voire plus
exécutifs régionaux là où vous avez
entièrement raison c'est que du coup la
notion de front républicain est beaucoup
plus complexe à mettre en oeuvre à
partir du moment où vous êtes dans un
système politique à 4 forcée pl3 force
des quatre forces d'aujourd'hui c'est la
gauche
la république en marche la droite et le
rn mais vous n'êtes pas ce donc voilà
avant vous aviez que trois forces la
gauche la droite et le rassemblement
national donc la force arrivé 3e pouvait
être obligé de soins elle se retirait
soit c'est une partie de ses électeurs
l'abandonnait tout simplement
donc on nationale à la fin c'est ce qui
s'est passé souvent cessé d un mouvement
des électeurs et mouvements chez les
électeurs eux mêmes qui font ça à 4
force c'est devenu plus compliqué parce
que vous dites mais pourquoi je martyrs
- surtout comme la gauche est morcelé
divisé son total peut-être supérieur au
total 2 par exemple de la république en
marche mais elle est arrivée derrière
alors qu'ils se retirent dans ce cas là
c'est un choix stratégique important
alors vous avez dit possibilité de
victoire oui la possibilité de victoire
dans des régions de du rassemblement
national existe et ce sera lui parce
qu'un scrutin
peu importe qui et alexis le disais tout
à l'heure peu importe qu'ils aient
beaucoup d'abstention
un scrutin est lui comme un enjeu
politique comme un événement politique
si le fn gagne
paca est conçu une région paca bon on
pourra dire c'est la maladresse etc et
ce sera renvoyé au débit de la macro ni
et en particulier de jean castex qui
s'est beaucoup engagée sur ce terrain si
en revanche vous avez à dire que c'est
la faute des républicains mais oui mais
maladroit que la grée tout ça deux
recommandent le figaro d'aujourd'hui qui
revient sur cette pièce deux ou trois
régions tombe un exécutif du
rassemblement national
vous avez un événement politique qui
transforme dans le regard des
observateurs mais dans le beaucoup
d'électeurs marine le pen en favori de
l'élection présidentielle
c'est à dire un autre regard et à ce
moment là aussi un niveau d'exigence
beaucoup plus élevé à son égard c'est à
dire ce que son programme est réellement
cohérent est ce qu'une élection de
marine le pen est un atout pour la
france dans le monde en europe dans
l'union européenne où va être au
contraire une catastrophe pour la france
dans l'union européenne csah des débats
qui va y avoir dans l'année qui vient
et enfin j'en termine la question de
savoir si emmanuel macron et le bon
candidat pour l'affronter c'est là la
question de la pause et c'est le sait le
l'avers et le revers effectivement une
victoire de marine le pen dans une deux
trois régions change le regard sur
marine le pen
en fait la favorite mais peut aussi dans
une certaine mesure réactiver le le
front républicain pour la présidentielle
c'est à dire que tout du coup j'en dise
ah mais elle peut gagner et donc ça peut
être ça peut avoir un effet inverse à
plausible une victoire une victoire peut
galvaniser les partisans ont mobilisé
les adversaires donc ce n'est pas
absolument univoque m'enfin moi je
trouve comme mieux gagner une fois pour
gagner la deuxième que perdre mon que
c'est bien mieux de gagner que les
bonnes questions pour axa
oui mais le revers c'est en creux la
stratégie de macron si marine le pen
gagne une deux trois régions facile ces
candidats gagnent tout à coup la la la
prétention à mâcon de d'être le barrage
celui qui est le mieux à même de
d'empêcher vecteur de front national
tient beaucoup moins les gens vont dire
ah bah oui mais ça pas tellement marché
en paca votre tactique en tel endroit
votre tactique donc du coup toute la
stratégie de mâcon et devient difficile
à soutenir et du couvre reviennent des
questions sur est ce qui peut-être que
même qu'il est maladroit 2 ira peut-être
qu'on avait on aurait intérêt à se
trouver un candidat
voilà pour la fin on en est encore loin
cqfd c'est à dire que quand on cette
analyse si elle est solide elle aboutit
à ce que pour macro et la république en
marche l'urgence absolue est d'éviter
des victoires du rassemblement national
dans les régions et donc s'il le faut de
retirer les listes de la république en
main je pense particulièrement à la
région bourgogne franche comté c'est
maryse a eu fait la présidente
socialiste elle a pris les communistes
sur sa liste en d'autres termes les
communistes n'acceptons jamais une
fusion avec la république en marge dont
or le rassemblement national est très
fort si donc là c'est typiquement le cas
où la question se pose pour la
république en marche se retirer pour y
glisser sans accord et c'est pour ça que
c'est l'étranger lui c'est prévoir il
est comme comme dans les outrances me
semble-t-il c'est que l'idée avant
l'élection qui vont nous demander nos
voix ils vont de notre accord à
l'arrivée quand on s'est présentés soi
même comme le barrage au front national
on est obligé de se retirer et ça peut
se trouve se retrouver car de ladite
dans les hauts de france si xavier
bertrand est derrière au premier tour
sébastien chenu c'est pour lui un très
grave affaiblissement en vue de la
présidentielle parce que vous allez
avoir valérie pécresse et laurent
wauquiez qui dans leur région vont
arriver 15 points devant le
rassemblement national être sûr de leur
réélection n'avoir besoin d'accord avec
personne etc et vous avez un bertrand
qui à ce moment là serait devancé marc
chenu au second tour et dont tout le
monde se dira mais que va faire la
république en marche ou pas ce serait un
affaiblissement sérieux revers jeu sa
candidate inverse à mme bertrand qui
gagne tout seul parce qu'il est devant
le front national qui ne demandent rien
à personne et qui peut faire la
démonstration
vous voyez muselier va faire ami ami
avec les maquereaux nist hyper dans
l'hypothèse où il perd moi je reste
droit dans mes bottes et je tiens mon
programme jusqu'au bout je gagne c'est
un
c'est au fond la stratégie qu'il faut
mener la présidentielle ça ça tu assez
convaincant comme démonstration mais
effectivement 30 ans le jeu du premier
tour et le premier tour ce dimanche
proche
exactement il nous reste un peu moins de
deux minutes je mangeais une question
subsidiaire à vous poser les si le rm
comme à la production présidente ne
remporte aucune région sa courbe est ce
que ça compromet définitivement les
chances de marine le pen c'est très
lourd parce que ça veut dire que ce
parti est très fort très puissant qu'il
a une stratégie d'enveloppement dont on
vient de parler et qu' il reste la force
répulsive qui fait qu'au second tour de
ce scrutin les électeurs ne veulent pas
lui donner la victoire
c'est donc un message politique qui
serait très fort car votre hypothèse par
exemple c'est qu'en paca
il y aura un renversement suffisant pour
permettre à muselier de sauver la sa
présidence probablement grâce au retrait
de la gauche et grâce à des
mobilisations des lecteurs mais ce sera
effectivement un message très sévère
pour marine le pen qui en plus a eu le
tort elle je trouve la peau en jambes et
le scrutin je suis pas d'accord sur ce
point elle a dit j'ai besoin de victoire
aux régionales de présidence régionale
et départementale pour avoir des
soutiens suffisants quand je serai au
pouvoir dans le pays
c'était au sens où on ne s'était pas
présenté à une a alors ce sens là et
très juste merci je veux vous souscrivez
à l'analyse de sur quels points sur le
fait qu' effectivement si on n'est pas
du tout si le jeu n'est pas bien pas du
tout le mal qu'elle s'est donnée
notamment tout ce recentrage qu'un
véritable effort conceptuel si en dépit
de ça elle continue de faire peur c'est
vraiment que l'on veut dire les français
n'en veulent pas et là partir à la
bataille présidentielle avec l'idée que
les français n'en veulent pas c'est
comme un énorme handicap parce que ça
sert à rien de faire des gros scores de
toute façon la fin des faits on perd
toujours c'est un peu comme le football
alors à propos de football sebaï toute
dernière question c'est une question
d'actualité un qui a un impact politique
c'est si les bleus mettent un genou en
terre ce soir en hommage aux
blacklight matters the larger un peu le
débat est ce que c est ce que c'est un
geste qui peut avoir un impact sur sur
l'opinion aujourd'hui jérôme scoop ans
très franchement on ne leur demande pas
de mettre un genou à terre on leur
demande de mettre des buts dans les
filets allemands
c'est comme ça que tous les français
vont avoir ce sentiment ça va je pense à
gacé une partie des gens mais ça n'a pas
grande importance s'il gagne tout le
monde aura oublié tout le monde leur
pardonneront le demandera vous faut
mettre les deux genoux par terre faites
ce que vous voulez gagner
si en revanche hyper de me dire ah voilà
au lieu de faire au lieu de faire les
malins mettre le genou à terre ils
auraient mieux fait de jouer mais ça
dépendra de la suite de la compétition
débute bon on est dans le temps
additionnel du coup et comme c'est la
première phase il n'y a pas encore de
tirs au but et prolongation donc on
s'arrête ici merci beaucoup d'avoir en
tout cas câble commenté analysé c'était
passionnant je donne juste la parole à
nos internautes qui étaient là avec nous
ce matin nathan geoffrey raison marie le
pen a fait des efforts elle semble avoir
travaillé ces dernières interventions le
ses dernières interventions le montre et
roland nous dit ce n'est pas pour autant
que les électeurs voient en marine le
pen quelqu'un de sérieux le problème est
posé on vous posez la question justement
sur twitter c'était un pronostic pensez
vous que marine le pen a des chances
réelles d'accéder au pouvoir et là
encore il ya des internautes ont été
partagés 51 % répondent oui et 49 %
répondent non et bien ça nous donne tout
toute latitude et est plein d'arguments
pour suivre cette élection sur figaro
live et ne vous inquiétez pas il va y
avoir d'autres rendez vous si vous nous
regardez maintenant en direct à 11h 30
vous restez avec nous vous avez rendez
vous avec le toque à 12 heures yves
thréard soit christian estrosi et on
retrouve yves thréard ce soir à partir
de 19h30 pour ça qu'on a enregistré un
peu en avant en avance parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à organiser avec un
grand débat sur le programme économique
des candidats à la région en
ile-de-france à vivre en direct sur
figaro live et on se retrouve demain
également pour point de vue et il y aura
demain soir d'ailleurs également un
autre débat
avec lci et rtl ce qui sera concernée
qui concernera pas qu'à bas et bien sûr
la soirée électorale dimanche mais on y
reviendra d'ici là merci reste avec nous
distillation figaro life
[Musique]